-Performing "Crystal Glass" from
their new album "Ashamed,"
here's Mad Foxes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I write notes
in the back of the bus ♪
♪ I sing songs
and carry the curse ♪
♪ Way too good for me ♪
♪ Choking on my mistakes ♪
♪ I'm walking on crystal glass ♪
-♪ Crystal glass ♪
-♪ Walking on crystal glass ♪
-♪ I stutter on a he-he-hello ♪
♪ Lately,
spit is all I swallow ♪
♪ Riffle is the smell ♪
♪ Trigger is the smile ♪
♪ I'm walking on crystal glass ♪
-♪ Crystal glass ♪
-♪ Walking on crystal glass ♪
-♪ With you my dear ♪
♪ Nooooow ♪
♪ Look at me ♪
♪ Say my name ♪
♪ Oh, look at me ♪
I blame all the buddies
and any forehead
crushed-can contest.
BBQ ribs, jerseys, sport socks,
and locker-room talks.
Endorphin, dolphins,
aqua parks and confidence!
♪ Crystal glass ♪
-♪ Crystal glass ♪
-♪ Walking on crystal glass ♪
-♪ With you my dear ♪
♪ Nooooow ♪
♪ Look at me ♪
♪ Just say my name ♪
♪ Say my name ♪
♪♪
♪ Name ♪
♪ Naaaaame ♪
♪ Look at me ♪
♪ Say my name ♪
♪ Say my naaaaame ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]